こんにちははじめしゃちょーです皆さんは
バイクというものをご存知でしょうか一応
初めてちょっとね車の免許も持ってますし
バイクの免許も持ってますで普段移動とし
て乗るのが車一応小型のバイクを1台持っ
てましてちっちゃい移動とかなんか
コンビニ行ったりとかちょっとした買い物
行ったりする時にはそういうバイクを
ちょっと乗ったりするんですけどもあのー
どうしてもどうしても
欲しいバイクが見つかってしまいました
あの別にそんなバイク乗りとかじゃないん
ですけども僕元々バイクっていうものが
すごい好きでそれはアニメの影響とかなん
ですよねなんかファイナルファンタジー7
の主人公クラウドバイクめっちゃかっこ
いいの載ってたりアニメの東のエデンって
いうやつの主人公もバイク乗ってたり
アニメのアキラという映画でも主人公が
バイクめっちゃかっこいいの乗ってたりし
てて結構そのなんかリアルな世界という
よりそういうゲームとかアニメの世界の
この影響でバイク買って乗りてえなって
思うことが多くて大学時代に原付買おうか
なと思ってたんですけどもいや原付買う
ぐらいだったらバイクの方が良くねと思っ
てちょっと大学時代お金がなかったから
そんな高いバイクも買えないし
維持費が高いのもちょっとやだなと思って
駐輪場に止められる小型のバイクを買い
ましたという感じで小型のバイクずっと
乗ってたんですけどもあのもうね俺決め
ました
欲しいバイクが見つかりましたでもう買い
はい今日はその購入したバイクを見に
ちょっとバイク屋さんに来ております埼玉
県のバイク屋さんハトヤというところに来
ておりますちょっと今日その購入した
バイクに初対面ということで早速会いに
行きたいと思いますどういうバイクかと
言いますとねもうこれ見たらわかると思う
んですけども
めちゃくちゃ僕の性癖に刺さってます
ちょっとそれをまずねとりあえずあの見に
行きたいと思いますでは行きましょう
どうもというわけでバイク屋さんに行き
ました大量のバイクありますねすごい数
置いてありますただその僕バイクも見たい
というよりかは欲しいバイクも1個だけ
あってそのために今回来てるのであのすい
ません正直
バイクのこと何も知らないです知識0何も
バイクのこと知らなくてもう本当はただ
乗りたいだけのにわかみたいな感じなん
ですけれどもせっかく来たのでちょっと
色んなバイク見ていきたいと思います
サーブのバイク乗りたい乗りたいです
僕はドラッグスター乗りたいです
[音楽]
[拍手]
ちょっと見ていきましょうか
これとかめっちゃ人気をもう最悪済みされ
てるんですけども川崎の忍者っていう
バイクですねこれスポーツ型のフルカウ
ルっていう周りがこういうカウルっていう
カバーされてるのをフルカウルって言うん
ですけど横からめっちゃかっこいい
うわ
かっこいい
[音楽]
こんなもんですかね
1000ccの忍者
めちゃくちゃでかいですねこれ大型ですね
全部
忍者ですね
[音楽]
かっこいいここら辺がオフロードバイクっ
ていうその山道とかも走れるっていう結構
あの面白いというか焦りを楽しめるバイク
[音楽]
俺詳しいな
これも人気ですCBR
ヤマハかな本場でした
何これ
めっちゃでかい
[音楽]
CDX1300っていうホンダのバイク
ですね結構アメリカとかも好きなんです
けどこういうなんかわかる近未来型という
かちょっと未来っぽいバイクも好きなん
ですよお値段ご覧ください
え本当だトライとかのこの3つっている
タイヤ3つなの
これもバイクなんです
一応バイク
[音楽]
やばいぞ
いやいやいやいや
かっこいいねかっこいいですね
[音楽]
こうやってなんか前輪がこうなるやつ
わかりますやっぱそこが長いほどイケてる
んですか
[音楽]
こんだけかっこいいと値段も結構
100万円
レベルだレベルこれ有名なやつよ
[拍手]
ちょっとアメリカン気味じゃない確かに
レベルもよく聞きますね人気の車種だった
はずですSR400ね
これも結構クラシックな感じで人気なん
ですよいやーすごいねすごいですね色んな
種類のバイクがあってテンションが上がり
ましたが今回僕が買うバイクここには今
ありませんので別の場所に置いてある
みたいなので早速見に行っていいですか
どういうバイクって言われてるかって言う
とそのアキラっていう映画に出てくる
バイクめっちゃかっこになる赤いやつ
巷ではアキラバイクと言われていますだ
から今持ってる小型のバイクが結構
アメリカンぽいんですけど今回買った
バイクアメリカンというよりかは近未来型
見た目がもう本当に
好みすぎてちょっと
購入することを決意しましたじゃあ早速見
ていきましょう
はいというわけで早速この奥に私が買う
バイク
到着しておりますので行ってみたいと思い
ます
まず1回も見てないからまだじゃあ行き
ますね
失礼します
[音楽]
ありました
こちらです
[音楽]
見て見て5
倍約分にはじめ様すごい
これが実物かっこいいどうですかこの
デザインいやめっちゃかっこいいという
わけでついにご対面しましたこちらもう
ずっと気になってはいてかっこいいな
かっこいいなと思ってたんですけれども
人生一度きりなので欲しいバイクには
乗ろうと思ってついに買いましたNM4
02です
どうこの見た目動作かっこいいですアキラ
バイクって言われてるのがなんかわかると
いうかちょっと近未来っぽいデザインに
なってるんですよちょっと
三角になっちゃってる普通のバイクは三角
ではないここ三角になってるし顔がもう
完全に未来なのよ色々ちょっと調べたん
ですけどもなんか手元にヒーターが付いて
て
冬場とかあったかいらしいんですよあと
やっぱ荷物の積載量とか持ち込みます
01がここがちょっとなくて小さかったん
ですけど02からこの
積載というか物載せれる場所が大きくなっ
たっていうちゃんと調べてました
荷物がたくさん載るようになったのが02
でタンデムでここ人も乗せれますし足場も
あると後ろ見てどう誰かここを見てバイク
だと思うだろういい意味でバイク
らしからぬというか今までだったバイクと
は違う形をしててもうマジでこれに乗り
たいちょっとどうしても欲しくてこの
バイク買いましたえっとこれまた買っ
ちゃっていいんですか
ね多分
聞いてみるか聞いてみるか
また買ったりしてみても
大丈夫です
[音楽]
レンジになった
いいんですか
失礼しますまたがります
ここでいいことじゃないと思うんですけど
も
大型バイクの免許持ってないんですよ
実はですねあの大型バイクの免許まだ持っ
てません買った後に取りに行きますなので
ちょっとあの運転はできないんですけど
ちょっとまたがるだけまたがってみます
じゃあ行きます
やばい
ありがとうございます
助かりました
[音楽]
[拍手]
せっかくなのでちょっと外出してみて
もらいたいと思いますマジでかっこよく
ない超かっこいいあれよりかっこいい
バイクないと思ってるんだよね
02今来ました
でかすぎてギリギリ
[音楽]
ネーム4このバイクいろんな場所が開くっ
ぽいのでちょっと見てみたいと思いますお
願いしますまずはこの部分ここは開くと
三角のボタンがあってこれを
押すと
こっちにも同じカバーが
付いてここはセキュリティ上下関係を回し
ながら
押さないと開かなくてここには
ETC
本当で結構入りそうカッパとか
あーなるほどなるほど
ここも荷物小さいものが入ると
疲れてき
たら回しながら
持ち上げると
誰がご飯あーこれ1人乗り用で
疲れた時はここですなんか手暖かくなるの
とかありましたけど
すごいバイク乗ってるとわかると思うん
ですけど
冬とか手がめちゃくちゃ冷たいんですよ
手の甲とかそういうのもあっためてくれる
機能もついているというやつです
[音楽]
はいというわけでnmo02買いました
ただの皆さんも引っかかってると思うん
ですけども先ほど僕の発言にありました
このバイクを運転する
免許持ってません
このバイクですね
排気量が750ccで大型バイク大型二輪
のバイクになるんですよで僕持ってる免許
が中型の2輪中型二輪
[音楽]
の限定僕ですねあの125cc以下まで
しか運転できないのでもう750円なんで
持ってんの他そもそも250ccそして
400cc中型バイクすらも実は運転でき
ないんです
それでも欲しかったもうなんかバイクに
乗りたいってより俺この子に乗りたくて
免許を取る前にバイクを買わせていただき
ましたなので今の僕にはこのバイクを運転
してる資格がありませんもう俺は自分を
追い込みましたもう免許を取るしかないと
いうわけで初めて社長
順番が逆になってしまったんですがこの
バイクを買ったので大型二輪の
免許を取りに行くことをこの動画で使わせ
てくださいもう使うとかじゃないです取る
しかないんですじゃないと乗れないんです
勝った意味がないんですよさっき教習所に
電話したところ中型免許の限定という免許
を持っているんですけどもそれを大型に
するためには20時間の実績教習20時間
受けるだけでとりあえず大型免許は取れる
ぽいので
意外とすぐ行けるんじゃないかなとも思っ
てます20時間でしょ1日3時間受けると
1週間ぐらいで行けると
行く時間があるのだろうかそこは結構
ネックになってくると思うんですけども
ちょっと夏休み以降なんとか時間を見つけ
て教習所に通い免許を取ってこのバイクに
乗りたいと思いますこれもね俺作戦として
ありだと思うのよ免許があるからバイクを
買うんじゃなくてバイクがあるから免許を
取るなんかモチベーションすごいと思うん
ですよ教習所での
ドリフトしちゃいそうというですね
ちょっと
疑問に思った人いると思いますあれはじめ
大型の免許持ってたっけって持ってません
今から取るんです
バイク乗ってる人がいます
羨ましい今の僕には乗る資格がないんです
またがることしかできない行動に出ること
も許されないんですけど
必ずや近いうちにこのバイクに乗ります
[音楽]
はいというわけでNM402
俗に言うアキラバイクをゲットしたはじめ
しゃそうでしたがまだ乗れないという動画
でした
君もバイクに乗りたいんだってなはい
どうする
免許を取り行きたいです
じゃあ一緒に行くかお願いしますじゃあ
ちょっと
夏終わったら取りに行こう一緒に勉強行き
ましょうお願いします目標はツーリングだ
なそうですね
僕は持ってないんですけどもバイク欲しい
気持ちだけが高ぶっちゃってるので
ちょっと何とか一緒に
免許は取りに行きたいと思います
頑張ろうな頑張りましょう他にあるのか
というわけで買わせていただきましたNM
42あきらバイクのお値段発表したいと
思いますからね
お値段91万7310円
約91万円ぐらいです
高いよ高いけど車と比べたらやっぱ
ちょっと安いなと思いますしこれ結構調べ
たんですけどもバイク屋さんで取り扱っ
てるお店も結構少なかったのでかなり
希少価値は高いかなと思いますなんかね
結構いろんな色あったんですけどももう俺
はねちょっとあのクラウドリスペクトで黒
にしたいなと思いました一番かっこいい
これかはい
教習所行ってき